va's mission is to serve veterans is not
to help ice and the border patrol which
we have the documents which on on their
websites and from a memo it's not to
help them they should be spending all
their time processing the claims for
veterans not for other agencies not for
unauthorized migrants it's a fact that
they are doing it and because of that
veterans are suffering and they are ones
getting bills and providers are leaving
the system it's totally corrupt and it's
got to be investigated it's got to be
stopped that was Air Force veteran
Darren selnick with us last weekend
America's veterans calling out the va's
role in processing medical care for
illegals were entering the country while
those who risk their lives for our
freedoms still wait to be treated our
next guest is demanding answers from the
Biden Administration Republican
Congressman uh Mike Bost is the chair of
the house Veterans Affairs committee he
joins us now Mr chairman thanks for
being here I know you're very passionate
about this issue uh and proactive so VA
denies they're doing this they always do
that uh but and they say they're just a
middleman uh for care that illegals need
yet we also know that they're denying in
many places access to Community Care for
vets so why are we facilitating care for
illegals but not being as robust as we
can for community care for
veterans well first off Pete thank you
for having me on and let me tell you
thank you for continuing after this you
know we all know that President uh Biden
has called this border problem they can
claim that that it's not him but it is
him you know I was just on the border
last spring uh and and dealing with the
veterans who are actually border patrol
agents and and making sure they were
receiving the services they need but it
just came to us in October this Brave
whistleblower who's a border agent that
came and said uh that that that VA was
paying for health care and I still don't
have all of the facts but a p VA is
direct not directly providing to the IM
immigrants it seems VA is a middleman
between the Department of Homeland
Security and the hospitals but the Biden
Administration has to answer to
taxpayers and Congress and as of yet the
VA has not answered us so we're still
continuing to aggressing to go after
this VA s resources should always be
directed to the veterans period and I
believe that we must expand the the
improve vaac care in the community to
ensure veterans and health care that
that they need they're receiving it and
it's not being siphoned off uh to this
border problem that was not caused by
these veterans matter of fact you know
there's many veterans as I said are
working as border patrol agents right
now and they need to make sure that we
provide for them I think that's an
important note that it was a
whistleblower that came forward from
border patrol because they noticed and
by the way if you go to these websites
uh which Darren selnick and others at
Concerned Veterans for America have done
there are links to places which point
out the fact that illegals are having
their Healthcare facilitated through the
VA system so it's it's not something
they're denying in that sense per se but
you're trying to get to the bottom of
how pervasive that is also do you do you
feel like veterans are being served in
Community Care meaning if you can't be
seen at a facility you can go out into
the community as aggressively as they
should be or is the B Administration
slowing that see that that's the problem
this is using that system that makes
sure that we are able to pay for that
Community Care that our veterans need I
don't care whether it's the VA or in the
community our veterans have to have the
services they need when they need it the
quality that they deserve because
they've earned it now when we start
talking about this though this is the
they're using the tool and mechanism
that's used to pay Community Care even
though they're reimbursing the VA for it
so they say they are not because that
takes away the the the the level at
which uh they can focus on making sure
we're providing for our but but Pete
this adds to this this looks at a bigger
problem look for two years the Biden
Administration every agency went
unchecked why because the Democrats were
in control now you're seeing us
aggressively finding all the things that
I know you and I have talked about you
know and we need to hold them
accountable if you remember there was a
a a a a a an administrative rule that
Trump put in place that allowed him and
you were a supporter of this that
allowed them to aggressively handle Med
middle managements and and when handling
middle management uh they could fire
them if they were doing bad things
that's right we've had sexual harassment
by upper echelon uh that that were
supposed to be over stopping sexual
harassment so yeah these are we're
trying to get to all of these problems
absolutely under the Trump
Administration you could fire middle
managers at the VA for cause you could
also allow vets to go outside into the
community if they couldn't be seen at
the VA the B Administration has tried to
reverse effectively reverse both of
those things now we find out they're
using the VA system to help facilitate
healthcare for illegals uh chairman uh
boss thank you for being all over this
keep us
updated thank you for having me on you
got it I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kil me
and I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis